so I've been on the other side of the so
so when we were doing our idea lab I
worked this guy Michael birch Michael
birch was is known as if you just google
he's like one of the top growth guys in
the world he sort of was doing an
invented viral marketing before viral
marketing was a word he did it because
he didn't have money back in the day so
he built one of the first address book
importers where for this company called
birthday alarm he had he was like and I
think he did it before that at a Marinis
company I forget what that was called
birth homes before that so so berkland
was the first one where he was like hey
I want people to send this to their
friends what if I just imported all the
addresses from their hotmail and then I
made it easy push this button to send it
and he's like he literally told me at
his house he was like I thought that ten
days later like I thought there's no way
they let this go for more than ten days
and he's like it's now been 15 years and
this thing still works and he's like so
he was working on viral marketing cuz he
just didn't have a budget so he's like I
gotta use my customers to get me more
customers and to explain it you didn't
explain it totally clear but someone
signs up for your thing it says do you
want to invite your friends here's your
gmail contacts click select all and send
an email to all of them and so in this
case for birthday alarm it was I make a
calendar where I'm all in vite you I'll
say hey say I'm can you add your
birthday to my calendar I don't want to
forget your birthday this is before
Facebook cases by the way and so you
would add your birthday to my calendar
and they would hasten it would say hey
Sam don't you want to remember Shawn's
birthday that'd be nice like reciprocate
and you bill yeah sure and then he would
say hey Sam you got one birthday on the
calendar but you surely got more friends
than one so why don't you invite some
other friends here let me make it easy
for you would you like to import all
your friends from hotmail and you're
like yes and then and he added one thing
at a time to make it more viral so he
would add a prefilled message he's like
oh there people are stopping because I
can't think of what to say right so
here's a pre filled message that I know
works and then I just say sent and so
then he got this thing super viral so
you know birthday alarm grew to 50
million members with zero paid marketing
50 million and and then he's done this
again and again since then with the
social network Bebo and others so when I
worked with them the name of the game
was viral growth and so we did a charity
campaign
they're trying to raise money for
charity water well we made a story a
website that was just telling a story of
this boy jean bosco with no water and
then we said can we get this to go viral
and so we did the same thing import
import emails get people to send the
story to their friends and raise money
for the cause and we got it to go viral
so I've literally been Bennett we're
like nothing nothing nothing you'd come
into work nothing no growth no growth no
growth and you would just tweak the
right thing and then all of a sudden
that you know between overnight
something would have double and the next
morning it doubled again next morning
double began and I remember it just
going from zero to five million people
signing up for this charity thing within
like you know two weeks it was insane
and so I've seen viral growth and how
counterintuitive it is like you don't
think you know we will yesterday we had
4,000 people so today we're gonna have I
don't know 5,000 6,000 it's like no
you're gonna have 16,000 then you have
32,000 and there's gonna you know it's
gonna go up to the millions within a few
days and so I've seen viral growth when
you're talking about in the good sense
from a product perspective now it's
viral growth of an actual virus
and so and it you can see actually in
the u.s. somebody did a great graph
where they mapped Italy where everything
is on lockdown because Italy is started
spreading like crazy and they showed
Italy day one us day one
Italy day two the u.s. day two number of
cases and the bar graphs are like
identical and the thing is we're just in
like whatever day six and you can see by
day 21 where this thing gets to if you
don't like lock everything down right
away so I am very fearful because I've
seen viral growth I've seen viral spread
and I know that it doesn't work the way
I breaks our brains our brains think
things go linearly but this goes
exponentially and it's really hard to
just comprehend an exponential spread
and to take this story a different way
than coronavirus which is that stuff
that you're describing that Michael
purchasing you can actually still get
all these two cool plugins that auto
automatically like allow people to share
a pre-populated message to all their
gmail contacts we use it and people
still share yeah and the math works out
where you know because you would think I
would never do that wouldn't even all my
content we had a lot of people doing it
but people do it and what happens is you
know 1% or less will do it but you look
at the math one
some people do it on an average they
have 326 contacts so for every hundred
people that come in you get three
hundred twenty six people blasted out it
doesn't work as good as that time
because the email open rates are much
higher than yeah but now people are like
I don't know I never talked to Sam so if
he's sending me this this is junk this
is spam
now people filter it but in certain
countries it works like we were growing
like we could do this like clockwork in
India in India people still open it like
they did in the US ten years ago and
they forward even higher rates I don't
care look forward everything everybody
and so India Turkey all these little
countries where we would see this crazy
growth that you couldn't get in the US
and or UK anymore they kind of suck
because the monetary value in you know
the value per user is lower there but it
does still feel good to get like it
definitely works and people are shocked
by that yeah we did one through SMS I
remember and over the weekend and went
viral and like you know during the week
Monday through Friday everything looked
fine is growing but like not at a crazy
pace we didn't realize the viral
coefficient was 2 and so over the
weekend it took off and started
compounding on a big number and we
racked up 120,000 an SMS 130,000 dollar
bill and SMS is going through Kazakhstan
I was like we don't even know we're
growing we're gonna grow in Kazakhstan
and it went crazy and turns out texting
in Kazakhstan is super expensive and so
$120,000 in two days we had to pay off
that's crazy
[Music]
you